bueno buenas tardes la verdad que
estamos muy contentos con la
participación estamos batiendo récords
históricos casi 38 millones de personas
han votado por correo y 17 en persona en
aquí en estado de florida estamos muy
pendientes del voto hispano es un estado
bisagra y estamos todavía luchando para
convencer a todos aquellos
hispanoamericanos que no lo tienen claro
al igual que texas ohio wisconsin o
carne del norte serán estados claves y
por primera vez en la historia el voto
hispano aumentará y será significativo
al igual que el de las mujeres que será
absolutamente determinante que les dice
a los hispanos y como ha respondido el
partido republicano ante las críticas
previas a las presidenciales en temas
como la pandemia la recesión económica o
las protestas contra el racismo
bueno yo el mensaje que le enviaría a
los hispanoamericanos es que tengan
mucho cuidado con votar a un partido
demócrata radicalizado que ha demostrado
que es está llevado o tomado de los
grupos como antifa black size matters y
que además apoya el levantamiento de
embargo a cuba por lo cual afectaría
absolutamente a la geopolítica del
continente es importante también que
conozcan que el presidente de donald
trump ha llevado a cabo una orden
ejecutiva para la prosperidad hispana
que ha reducido los índices de desempleo
que ha reducido los impuestos y que en
materia inmigración ha controlado la
entrada ilegal masiva de inmigrantes
pero que a la vez ha ayudado a combatir
el tráfico humano es importantísimo que
nos movilicemos hay que votar
masivamente contra el socialismo contra
este partido demócrata que no nos
representa y que no nos va a favorecer